all right welcome back everyone to my
round five recap this is a special one
uh because in this game earlier today I
played none other than Anna kramling
who's been streaming all her games this
event and when pairings went up
yesterday I thought it was an April
Fool's joke Adam messaged me that we
were playing each other and I didn't
believe it but uh the pairing gods of I
guess wanted the content creators to
square off and um I should note that
Anna has been streaming all of her games
on her twitch Channel you should
definitely check it out her mom
Grandmaster pia cramling has been doing
commentary and did commentary for uh
three four hours that our game lasted
and it's been really really good content
like production quality is very good and
actually after our game we uh we
analyzed a lot on her stream so I'll
leave links in the video description to
check out not only her twitch Channel
but also her YouTube channel uh she's
been doing round Recaps uh just like me
so let's get into the game uh I'll admit
I was a little bit nervous going into
this game because I saw Anna's previous
games and I feel like she's a bit
underrated and um I mean she's just been
playing a ton of Chess over recent years
uh plays a lot online of course and um
she has a relatively flexible D4
repertoire with whites so I wasn't
entirely sure what to expect but I've
sifted through like all of her chess.com
games I knew to expect D4 on move one
and I Was preparing a few things mainly
nimso Indian and various Queens Gambit
decline structures but then she
surprised me on move two with the move
Bishop to G5 and uh this is not a move I
could have predicted I don't think she's
played this almost ever she did mention
she played this once before but through
the thousands of games I looked at I did
not come across any with Bishop G5 uh so
this is a trompowski opening and it's
actually a line that I've avoided in
recent years because I've been a little
bit lazy to study this from the lock
side the way to avoid this is just by
playing D5 on move one which I usually
play going for a more traditional
Queen's Gambit or Queen's Camp declined
but after Bishop G5 I I still knew a few
things about what to do in the opening
and I was actually fortunate a few
months ago I I began studying uh some
courses through this website
chessmood.com a big shout out to
avatique Gregorian and Grandmaster and
his team has a lot of like just amazing
instructional content on uh on chess
mood and he has a whole black repertoire
and uh in one of the video lessons he he
covers extensively what to do against
the trumpowsky and I spent maybe about
half hour to hour watching The Core of
how to play this position is black so um
the the ideas weren't Super Fresh but I
knew the basic setup is to play Pawn to
D5
uh she played Pawn to E3 and actually I
was more prepared for Bishop F6 after
which I would take and then um and play
the structure but after E3 I was trying
to figure out what the best move order
is because there are some options for
black there's C5 there's 94.
um ultimately I decided on C6 which is
mainly just a flexible move
um I thought that maybe we could
potentially transpose into some like
semi-slave setup if I have three uh an
E6 C4 and then maybe I would go for
Cambridge Springs with Knight D7 and
eventual Queen A5
um the C6 also has an interesting trap
to it uh that if white plays C4
immediately
it's possible for black to essentially
be winning in the next two moves so I
can take the pawn and if light plays a
natural recapture black to move and win
a piece the common opening trap Queen A5
winning the bishop so white does have to
be careful not to blunder the bishop on
G5 and she didn't play C4 but she
relatively quickly played Bishop takes
F6 and then after ef6 I was kind of back
into my uh my chest mood preparation
um because after C4 I knew that black
should take your uh if I don't take the
pawn and let's say I play a move like
Bishop D6 this is actually a pretty
instructive example of how weak the
isolated Queen's Pawn can be because
from here white can play Knight C3 be
encount of the bishop on G2 bring the
Knight to F4 and put the queen on B3 and
there would be one two three four
attackers against D5 just a very weak
Pawn
I've made this mistake before so I knew
that black should take
um should take in this position on C4
and after Bishop C4 at first glance
maybe it looks a little bit
uncomfortable because Bach has zero
Center pawns and white has two Center
pawns but there's still control over the
center with um my C and F pawns and
there's relatively easy development both
my Bishops are open I start with the
move Bishop to D6 uh she develops
Knights I Castle Queen C2 and I play F5
and the idea of F5 is to eventually play
Knight D7 and Knight F6 and this is
still within my the realm of the opening
preparation where essentially black
wants to achieve nice harmony with the
pieces have good control over the E4
Square maybe eventually play G6 and then
um usually much later develop the bishop
there's cases where black plays Queen E7
Bishop E6 or sometimes even Pawn
storming on the queen side so yeah
generally when you're in the opening
phase like a position like this it's
good to have a sense of where the pieces
will ultimately go
uh now she played Knight F3 here and I
played Knight 2 D7 and I really wanted
to scream oh no my Pawn uh but in a
classical tournament you're not really
allowed to make much noise
so um I just silently thought it to
myself and of course she didn't take my
Pawn even though it looks free not
everything in life is free and in this
position if you want to find the move
for back twin material feel free to
pause the video of course we can see the
queen is aligned with the black bishop
and there's very nice move Knight E5
hitting the queen hitting the bishop and
preventing Queen D3 so black would be
winning material here so the pawn is
poisonous it's a very important life
lesson to don't eat poison so instead of
consuming the pawn she attacked the pawn
with the bishop now this move I think is
maybe a small inaccuracy because the
bishop generally is Happy along this
diagonal and after Bishop D3 I'm happy
to play G6 and then have the pawn chain
and generally Bishops don't like to
stare at Pawn chains like this but then
she she played a really interesting
aggressive looking move to try and
justify Bishop D3 that move being H4 and
I was feeling a little bit of pressure
here because whites can be very quick to
attack if I'm not careful there's
already ideas of H5 and if I move the
Knight to F6 H5 can come and if I take
there's this extreme sack and this looks
just really bad for black
um
so I figured the only way to prevent
white from playing H5 is to play H5
myself
and generally it's not a great idea to
push the Pawns in front of the castle
King but in this case my pawns are
actually quite solid and they restrict
whites plans of attacking G4 is very
hard to achieve and for the time being
E4 is not the most attractive now I was
actually thinking that E4 is perhaps a
candidate move here she didn't end up
playing it if she does then the Center
opens up and the king is a bit
vulnerable there would be Bishop to B4
and uh yeah generally White Castle
before opening the center
so for that reason she decided to Castle
queenside and this was an interesting
decision it's basically committing to
having a shark game where whites will
try and attack on the king side and
supposedly I'll try and attack on the
queen side
um in hindsight for her it may have been
better to Castle kingside just because
the knights enjoy the the slower
maneuvering game white would have ideas
of like G3 and eventual Knight G5
perhaps maneuver with other Knights
expand on the queen side and I think
this is a more
um more patient approach for the
position but casting Queen side
definitely makes the game interesting
here I brought my knight to F6 and then
she surprised me but she played a move
which perhaps a position calls for is
Pawn to E4 and it's a very
transformational move because for one
the the sound enter opens up there's
trades on e4 and white is left with this
seemingly weak ISO Queen's Pawn but at
the same time White's controlling space
and there's now a direct idea of taking
on G6 and if I'm not careful here and
let's say I develop and she takes and
takes and takes then white could very
easily force a draw with Perpetual check
so I have to be careful of the potential
sacrifices and I opted for Queen to F6
and once I played this move I was
feeling relatively comfortable because
the king side is under control it's very
hard for white to get in this G4 break
and I have the two Bishops in a more
open position and
um if I'm not getting attacked then the
the bishop pair in this case can be a
very nice positional advantage
so from here she played King to B1 which
I think is very reasonable because
there's all these checks on the diagonal
and the King's just safer towards the
corner I play a tricky move rooked E8 uh
this does have a threat to it I wanted
to play Rook takes E4 Queen E4 and
Bishop F5 she of course acknowledged the
threat and played Bishop to D3 now
Bishop D3
was another inaccuracy uh she played
this move relatively quickly and it was
very understandable like I have a threat
and she just moves the bishop to a safe
square but here it's really important
for white to recognize the other
possibility
um and what she probably should have
done was play Knight to G5 which is a
more active way of Defending against my
threat and it actually forms a plan in
the position because now she uh would
unleash her F Pawn and if white can play
F3 and G4 then it's basically everything
white wants to achieve get the pawn
break and try and open files on the king
side now against this move I was gonna
play Bishop to F4 and we analyze this
position a little bit after the game and
uh I realize it's it's not so easy for
that because white can still play F3 and
if I win the pawn I essentially concede
the bishop pair and she still has G4 and
this would be a really difficult
position to just understand what's going
on because after takes there's Queen H2
ideas and yeah it's just a complete mess
so
uh fortunately for me I didn't have to
stress about that line Bishop D3 was
played and uh now I play Bishop to G4
and life was very good here given that
I'm completing development the lights
pinned to the rook and I'm threatening
to win a Pawn on F3 by just taking twice
or maybe not taking twice immediately
because there's still Bishop G6 ideas
but um there's there's still a lot of
pressure on White's position and if we
see from the timestamps I'm doing quite
well on the clock and she's spent a lot
of time here to play her next move
Knight to G5 actually only nine minutes
but uh still a decent amount of time and
in the moment it felt like this was
essentially going all out that she she
recognizes that it's a difficult
position and she's trying to create some
imbalances some chaos in the position
um and trying and exploits the F7 Pawn
uh with eventual Bishop C4 ideas
the problem for white here is I snag the
rook and then I'm the one who gets
initiative so I have Bishop F4 and this
was a very useful move just trying to
remove the knights and uh sadly for her
she had to move back to F3 and then I
played King G7 and yeah life was very
good because I'm up the exchange and uh
yeah it doesn't doesn't seem like white
has any compensation for it so from here
I thought the win would be pretty
straightforward but she was very
resourceful in fighting on and the game
continued Rook G1 ideas of playing Pawn
G4 I play Rook d8 and then she played
Pawn to A3 now after the game she
mentioned the line of uh something that
I actually completely missed the reason
why she didn't play G4 was after takes
takes black has a really cool move here
and during the game I was thinking oh in
this position
I'll play something like Bishop C7 and
hit the knights and okay black should be
doing well but there's an even cooler
move
I can sacrifice the queen queen takes D4
oh no my queen and then Rook E1 is
leading to checkmates
um and this would have been a really
aesthetic finish
um and that's why she played A3 is
because yeah white can't play G4 so soon
and it's important for light to at least
create some Luft
um so there's no back ring problems
uh so we didn't go into that line but uh
I was happy to play Bishop C7 now
essentially unleashing the queen so
preventing the g-pawn from moving and
here it's really not easy for white to
find a move and she played the move
which I was really not expecting upon D5
just uh essentially checking upon maybe
in desperation but trying to open the
position after I take she plays Bishop
E4 hitting the Rook I move back and then
finally Pawn G4 so it does seem like
there's some pressure here with um the
g-file seemingly uh guaranteed to open
however I do have a nice uh
counter-attacking move Queen F4 and she
told me after the game she did not see
this coming I'm hitting the bishop and
the pawn she decided to play Queen C3
check I play King G8 she plays Bishop
two C2 covering the bishop but then I
win the pawn and after Knight G5 I take
on F2 and here I thought I thought I'd
be winning with a couple more moves but
uh so he kept fighting she took on G4 I
played Queen E1 we trade queens and then
in this position I I kind of had an
embarrassing moment and uh there's a
clip of it on stream where I was so set
on playing Rook D2 I was calculating
lines like Rook D2 Bishop B3 and uh Rook
E2 going after the B Pawn and I reached
out my hand touched my Rook I moved it
to D2 and then I realized
there's Knight F3 there's a backwards
Knight fork and I would essentially
blunder back the exchange I'd still be
winning uh because I'm up enough pawns
but I didn't want to allow her to to win
one of my Rooks so thankfully I did not
let go of my Rook when I played Rook D2
and I put it back on D6 and thought for
a little bit uh before playing Rook to
D7 just a safer move and then a position
like this there's no reason to over
complicate things uh just trying to play
solidly and after Bishop B3 King G7 put
the king back on a dark Square she plays
Rook G2 played Bishop F4 she moves her
Knight back attacking the bishop Bishop
H6 Rook F2 F6 seems like everything is
under control here and then she plays H5
and when she plays H5 I thought I had a
simple way to close things out Rook D3
but now we're approaching the last
tricky moment of the game because with
33 seconds on our clock she found
a move that made me think for I think at
least five minutes she played the move
Rook to G2 leaving her Knights on pre
and
I mean there's a lot of winning options
for black but I was trying to find
something just Crystal Clean and I
really wanted to take the knights Rook
H3 but then she has Rook G6 and if I
move my king to H A I lose a bishop if I
move it to H7 at first I saw Bishop G8
King h8 black is winning but then
there's this move Bishop C2 and
um yeah there's still wins here for
black but I didn't want to have the
headache over all the possible discover
checks so I ended up rejecting Rook
takes Knight and
um other option I was looking at is Rook
takes Bishop but then after uh actually
white can take your first king H7 takes
rookie three King goes maybe C4 takes
takes I was trying to figure out this
position because I'm up a Pawn on the
queen side but my king is so far away
and if I take the pawn there's Rook F7
Rook B7 and I didn't want the queen side
to crumble
so instead of going for these
unnecessarily like weird tricky lines I
just played the move to shut down all
counter play on G5 even though it's a
little bit ugly uh chopping in my own
bishop and I now have two connected past
pawns and after Knight F4 I
um yeah I gradually make progress I give
back some material but now I'm up three
pawns and yeah then the pawns go
marching she plays Bishop F5 I'm happy
to simplify further and this G Pawn is
essentially Unstoppable there's one
final trick in the position and goes to
show her resourcefulness
um after G2 Rook f8 I don't want to play
King E4 blundering uh rookie eights
although I was curious during the game
if I play King E4 rookie 8 King F3 takes
King F2 I was curious if black is still
winning here but I didn't want to
actually find out during the game
so uh instead I play King G4 and
eventually the checks run out my king
finds shelter on a C file I think she
gave one more check or maybe she
resigned in this position just to show
Rook here King C2 and the pawn is
queening so that was a game
um I think there were a lot of
instructive moments especially from the
opening and early middle game and I
don't think she made any obvious plunger
as this game it was more just a few
small inaccuracies and choosing the
wrong plan from the early middle game
stages that led to White's position
falling apart but definitely some
lessons to take away and I do encourage
you if you want a more extensive
analysis of this game we had a great
discussion on her twitch Channel I'll
leave a link below I'm also really
curious to see her recap on this game
because she did a recap just like this
where she analyzes her takeaways so I
think she uploaded it maybe an hour ago
so I'm gonna watch that uh pretty soon
and then I'll upload mine hopefully
within the next next 24 hours of this
recording it's a long tournament I
actually played two games today so I
have one more game to recap uh the game
I played after playing Anna
um thankfully there are three more
rounds left and it's a game a day for
the final three days so I'm gonna try
and get some sleep it's almost 2 A.M
it's been a long day uh thanks everyone
for watching I really appreciate like
all the nice feedback and comments and
people cheering uh cheering for me or
Anna or anyone else playing it's it's
nice to see some people watching the
event and enjoying the chess so stay
tuned for more and I'll see you guys
soon